hello everyone welcome to rational
science directly from frankfort germany
it's nine o'clock over here nine o'clock
at night
anyways today we have a great day we're
going to be talking about a foul by the
name of nasim hadaman
and uh then we're gonna move on to
uh general relativity find out what
that's all about
and then we're going to have our science
critic in fact he we're going to analyze
general relativity also with him because
he raised an issue related to general
relativity and then we're going to deal
with the flat earthers one more time
because apparently they still
failed to understand the question
after five weeks five weeks they still
don't understand the question most of
them i can't say that everybody but they
don't you know a lot of them come over
here and they don't understand the
question
okay and then we're going to open up the
floor for questions that and comments
that people made since last time so
let's move on with this gentleman uh
same hadamay who is he what is he
about and fellow raised the issue says
nassim haramein has calculated a
geometric solution for the gravitational
field
[Music]
and
says in his latest paper quantum gravity
in the holographic mass he describes
gravity okay describes right uh in a
classical algebraic way by calculating
the density of the space both within and
on the outside of the event horizon of a
proton okay
what is this all about well it's about
this gentleman his name is naseem
haramein he's i think uh born in
switzerland of iranian parents and
apparently he does have some influence
from the east
in his upbringing his education his
experience right
and uh so let's find out what this is
all about well it says that he published
a paper it wasn't so recent this was in
2013
and i think it's the only paper he
published after 30 years of doing
research this is the best he came up
with so let's look at what he's all
about
here it is he says quantum gravity in
the holographic mass
he published it uh and um apparently new
scientists pick up picked up on it
and wrote a little article and then it
was scrapped away nobody ever read it
again okay so that's the situation with
with that
paper okay nobody's
paid any attention the establishment
certainly doesn't
uh
bow down to it okay
and so what is it that mr nasim or mr
adam
talked about in that paper here we can
synthesize it for you and that includes
also his
general thoughts okay on
physics if we can call it that
mathematical physics to be more
correct okay mathematics as we call it
here and this is a synthesis of his
train of thought his way of thinking
what he's proposing this is what he
concluded after 30 years of
investigation 30 years of doing
equations he finally came up with
where the best equation he could okay so
here it is okay
uh
i can i see this
oh this is incredible i can't see what
i'm supposed to show you
and i have no idea why
okay i'm gonna
[Music]
that's incredible i don't know why that
doesn't come up
uh
i hope
does anyone see that
because uh
i can't see it on your screen so if you
can see it let me know please but if you
can't see it i'm gonna have to
redo this somehow
uh let's see
give me a second here and see if i can
get it back
i still can't get it's invisible
it's like my robe folks i can't i can't
see it and i don't know why
okay i hope uh all my other ones are not
like that
okay so nothing to see no i can't see it
either and i have no idea why i can't
see it
this is incredible i hope all my other
ones are not the same way
okay
i don't know what else to do here
why won't i see this
i have no idea what happened here
okay
um
i'm just gonna have to read it out
that's all i can do
uh he says that he in in that paper he
says he's got an equation
which he calls my equation and he says
the exact gravitational mass of a black
hole that's what he calculated
he's saying his main conclusion is that
a proton
is a black hole
in fact all subatomic particles are many
black holes okay
he says it's a new theory also what he's
got and
his new theory is all about the ether
and that makes me kind of wonder because
the ether has been around for
3 000 years now
so how is it possible that you know he
cannot uh
that he's still bringing up the ether
after so many centuries okay he calls it
the fluid space
in other words he he equates ether with
space
and we're going to see that in a little
bit as well
and he calls it fluid space in other
words this ether is moving all around
and let's see if i can put this here
uh
see hopefully this one works
and that's what it looks like more or
less okay that's the ether and the wave
waving in the ether
okay so uh
this is uh he's saying it's a new theory
okay he's a wave
fellow essentially
and uh so he's saying that he invented
this new theory that's got the fluid
ether which is fluid space okay great
uh then he says uh he starts out his
reasoning if we can call it that he says
an atom is mostly empty space because
it's equal to
0.9999999 bunch of nines uh percent of
space
okay so if if that's what uh an atom is
most the empty space he says um
an atom
or matter in general
uh in general is pretty much space
they're both approximately equal space
and matter because
an atom is mostly empty space so he
equates something with nothing okay he's
going to say that something and nothing
are essentially the same in fact he says
it clearly says space matter
uh mass charge gravity electromagnetic
field there are no differences between
these things
now how clear
is that i mean that's
as clear as it gets
then he says that space time fluctuates
with intense energy what is that it's
the plank fluctuations uh which are the
vacuum energy and he says that gravity
is the fluctuation of the structure of
the vacuum so
he got all these uh notions
from his schooling from the
establishment that's where he gets all
this stuff okay
fine uh he hasn't said anything new
and uh and uh again he equates space
with matter and all these things he says
they're all the same thing he never
defines any of these terms nowhere okay
so you know you would think that he's
more into business
building a business empire than he is in
talking about physics okay
he's uh also a fan of uh maya he talks
about mayan secret geometry so he's a
fan of all these you know you got
several people out there that say that
the ancients knew more than we do and we
lost all this knowledge over time that
they knew a lot and you know somehow got
lost you got a lot of people that have
these
thoughts
and they have this opinion about what
happened in history
um
he's a tesla lover and let's see if we
can put that in there hopefully this
works
uh
this is mr tesla okay and this is what
he believed then so if you want to
understand the universe think in terms
of energy frequency and vibration not as
solid physical forms
so mr tesla was not into physical he was
into abstractions okay
and uh that's what he purported to
explain the universe with
he says if you only know the
magnificence of the three six and nine
you know mathematical numbers right then
you would have the key to the universe
this is what uh this poor fellow
believed in okay but i like the the next
one down here he seems to have a
contradiction he says the day science
begins to study non-physical phenomena
it will make more progress in one decade
than in all the previous centuries of
its existence
today scientist he continues says today
scientists have substituted mathematics
for experiments and they wander off
through equation after equation and
eventually build a structure which has
no relation to reality so on the one
hand he talks about math and
abstractions and on the other one he
criticizes the mathematicians because
they went more abstract they're talking
about
a lot of math and very little
experiments
so he seems to have a contradiction we
don't know if he vouched for math or not
in the end
but i like the last one says the gift of
mental power comes from god divine being
and if we concentrate on minds on that
truth we become in tune with this great
power my mother had taught me to seek
all truth in the bible
okay so that's good ol nikki for you
and
this fellow um
he's in the same boat essentially you
know i don't know if he says he believes
in god and all that but he is a little
uh transcendental we can call
spiritual right and it seeps into his
work okay you can see it in there
okay and uh finally he says that he
vouches for the holographic structure of
space-time
what is that all about
well let me show you here an example
okay so that you get an idea what the
holographic
uh
universe is this
this thing that came out of
black hole
studying of black holes
and string theory which is what they do
they're trying to unify
quantum mechanics with general
relativity the macro world you know the
world of the cosmos cosmic world which
includes black holes according to
general relativity and then on the other
hand you have the uh quantum world which
is all particles and the the way they
plan to bring these two
irregular uh disciplines or
the fields of study together
is through the black hole and what
they're studying is all the garbage that
falls into a black hole they say all
that all that matter
somehow gets reflected
on the surface
surface
of the vet horizon which as a lot of you
know is the region
of influence of a black hole where you
still have
supposedly the escape velocity of light
okay so this is what what uh how to
maintain is talking about this is what
he vouches for okay let's see if this
shows up yeah it does okay
his holographic universe if you look it
up on the wikipedia it says the
description of a volume of space can be
thought of as encoded on a lower
dimensional boundary
to the region in other words you have
this 2d universe and from there you can
project a hologram okay that's what
they're talking about this is what
they're all the math being done lately
especially by string theorists is all
about they're trying to find out all the
garbage that falls inside a black hole
and how it maps onto its surface okay
and here you see it on the right since
the holographic principle was inspired
by black hole thermodynamics which
conjectures that the maximum entropy in
any region
seals with a radius squared and not
cubed as might be expected so they're
talking about two-dimensional versus
three-dimensional right in the case of a
black hole the insight was that the
informational content of all the objects
that have fallen into the hole might be
entirely con contained in surface
fluctuations of the event horizon okay
the holographic principle resolves the
black hole information paradox within
the framework of string theory
well we don't know what this uh
information paradox is and what
information has anything to do with
physics information is a concept
information is not what you send out
information is what someone interprets
at the receiving end that's information
and to say that's got something to do
with physics the how uh the world works
how the universe works you know how
gravity works
well it's uh stretching the
imagination
i'd say the the brain a little bit these
people are
doing nonsense that's what kind of work
you're paying for at the universities
and that's what the governments are
supporting uh rich people who
donate money uh to the universities and
funding a lot of these projects that's
what they're funding they're funny these
people who are just doing equations on
the blackboard or wherever and maybe
with their computer who are on their
desk with pencil or paper crayons or
whatever
and they're doing equations and their
equations have to do with what with a
zero dimensional singularity
zero dimensional singularity which is
what i talked about the other day a
little bit which is you know you have
stephen hawking and you had another
fellow there an indian fellow
from oxford uh or cambridge oxford i
think it was
and whether they say they say yeah
chandrasekhar proved that's what he got
his nobel prize for he proved
that a black hole is zero dimensional
collapses to zero size zero volume
infinite density
so what matter are they talking about
that somehow
maps itself onto the 3d or the
surface
of the um
of the event horizon which is
the region of influence of nothing of a
zero dimensional nothing you have a
nothing there why because all matter has
been crushed out of existence there is
no matter
what is mass mass is the quantity of
matter or a measure of the quantity of
matter
matter has disappeared there's no
structure whatsoever inside a black hole
it's zero dimensional there's nothing
there
so
how how can it not have matter but it
has mass in zero dimensional size in
zero dimensional or zero dimensional
volume
there's nothing there and from there
they build this
this event horizon which is a region of
influence of supposing of that
singularity it's all nonsense it's all
math it's got nothing to do with reality
there are no such things as black holes
because a thing is that which has shape
and that which has shape has length with
and height especially if it's
in physics you know it's uh it's a real
thing so it's got to have a it's got to
be at least three dimensional black hole
doesn't meet those uh specifications
okay um
so before we can talk about uh
some of these things you know we have to
find out what uh specifically
uh mr hyrumin is about and what he's
about is what he what he tries to peddle
out there because he's really a
businessman he's not into physics at all
he's just trying to make money like so
many others out there and what does he
talk about well he talks about this he
talks about the interconnected universe
and for this he
pulls the shrine of saiyaf fatima and
that's in iran again that's where his
folks came from
and so he's got this thing as you can
see it's pretty much interconnected okay
so you see all these interconnections
that's why he's got that in his facebook
page
okay that's good what does he
interconnect the universe with
uh you know as a physicist you would
think that
he would try to interconnect the
universe somehow right so you would
think i mean
if he's talking about con connection
right between atoms between everything
in the universe he's saying everything
is connected is he talking about the
same thing that i'm talking about when i
say the universe is interconnected
physically interconnected i mean that's
what a physicist talk about that talks
about right
okay so let's find out now this is what
he is talking about he says here you
have quantum mechanics on the one side
which is all discrete particles and you
would think that he as a physicist would
be talking about what you see on the
right a connected universe where all
atoms are physically interconnected in
other words what you need to identify is
those little lines that unite or that
bind any two atoms and again we talked a
little bit about that last week so you
can look that up
question uh that arises is what connects
two atoms especially one vibrates and
affects the other one at a distance
either you put something in between or
you do black magic
okay so it can't be both ways so if you
put something in between we need to know
what that something is and what it looks
like you know identify it for us and
that doesn't mean you've seen it or you
tested it no it just means you imagine
it and you're gonna explain whatever you
explain your theory
what you're gonna explain with that
thing okay
and the reason i say this is that
interconnectivity between in the
universe has been around for i'd say
thousands of years it's not the first
time when someone thinks about a
universe that is interconnected
interdependent
here you have two examples one is the
hindus okay and they talk about the
interwoven
tapestry of cause and effect
and they really are not talking about
things as you can see they're talking
about social and moral they're talking
about the web of life energy
they're talking about concepts and
they're not interested in the physics
part of it they're they're trying to
tell you how to live okay they're trying
to tell you how to behave in society and
for that they start by saying look
you're supposed to treat nature properly
we need the plants we need the animals
you know et cetera et cetera it's got to
do with a lot of that and very little to
do with physics you won't find a
physical object that interconnects the
universe in all of hinduism
and just in case here's buddhism okay
same thing
and here you can they talk about
interdependence through space and time
causality uh that are interwoven through
the universe you know everything is
interconnected yeah by what and uh they
mentioned the fact that quantum
mechanics have more or less proven that
to them because
uh they talk about entanglement and they
say look if entanglement shows that this
atom affects that one uh we're pretty
much on the same boat uh they're saying
that everything's interconnected yeah
the problem is that no one has figured
out you know what um
what
interconnects us what physical object is
interconnecting the atoms the universe
the matter in the universe and no one
identified it not the buddhists not the
hinduism
and for sure uh
you know no one today so when uh haram
comes in there and says look
the universe is interconnected
he hasn't said something new
unless he puts a physical object in
there and shows up what
binds
two atoms two pieces of matter two
universes whatever okay so he's gotta
put something in there it doesn't put
anything in there he hasn't said
anything new
he's just repeated what the hinduists
and uh buddhists have said
for centuries
okay so here it is here's a summary
let's hope i can see this now yeah this
one came out okay
and he says the following says there is
a flow of the energy of the universe
inside you
whoa that that doesn't sound like
physics it sounds more like he's going
to sell you something how to behave how
to be a nice guy how to treat nature you
know he's going to talk about stuff
that's got nothing recommendations you
know nothing that's got to do with
physics
he says everything is connected through
this energy
oh my god energy as we found out the
other day it's a concept so you can't
say you connect something with energy
then he says space is what's connecting
everything these are
the statements taken out of his videos
by the way just like you read them there
space is what's connecting everything
what do you mean space connects space is
what separates not what connects space
is nothing
but of course he said space is something
and therefore he's connecting it with
this something what he doesn't do is
draw he doesn't illustrate this
something so that we can see what he's
talking about when he says that space
connects everything
he says space is the thing that connects
all things
so he's talking about space as a thing
he says that's the connector the the
binding thing
the thing that connects us to everything
physically right because i guess he's
talking about physics
has one little proton is connected to
all other protons in the universe spin
the one thing that connects us all
spin
so spin connects us okay what is he
talking about how can spin connect
anything is spin you know you spin atop
how does that connect you to the other
top
they're both spinning how are they
connected
then he says space-time is an energy
that connects everything so he's got all
these words he's got it it's all ether
the electromagnetic or
electrostatic field that we see as
matter is just a function of the
dynamics of that ether gravity is a
function of that ether and then again he
says space matters
mass charge gravity electromagnetic
field there are no differences between
these
things okay
they're all connected through quantum
fluctuations
so let's see he says uh what are the
connections he says there's energy space
spin space time ether and quantum
fluctuations that's what connects
everything
none of those are physical objects so
yeah he finally says it's really hard to
wrap your head around it
yeah no kidding
so again i think uh mr haramayn is uh
into something else he's into doing
business he's into trying to hit the uh
jackpot by um
you know running his company he's got a
little company in hawaii over there
and what he wants to do is see if he can
convince the world especially the
mathematicians that he's on to something
okay that's that's what he's up to
and uh just as a comparison here you see
this is what we're proposing we're
saying yeah we we are saying that all
atoms are physically
interconnected okay and so all those
lines that you see there those are what
we call the electromagnetic ropes and
they do bind any two atoms not like
they're pasted to the surface of the
atom it's that the ropes uh convert into
the atom which converts into a rope
which converts into an atom and so on
down the line there's a single thread in
the entire universe everything is uh
there there's
one thing only in the universe which is
the thread the universal thread and
that's what converts into ropes atoms
ropes atoms ropes atoms and so on down
the line okay so that's what we're
proposing so we do have a physical
connector there is no action at a
distance okay so that's the difference
on the other hand this valve talks about
energy and quantum fluctuation space and
stuff that is not stuff that's the
difference okay so when he says the
connected universe which is what his
sales pitch is for physics he also does
some other stuff out there you know uh
does a little bit of history he branched
off into other
line items because i guess he needed to
make money to keep his company afloat
and so he branched off into all these
other things but he kept this connected
universe which he's trying to see if he
can convince the establishment of
and yeah if you're going to connect it
with abstract concept you're not doing
much of a connection there's no binding
there no physical no physicality to the
whole
thing that you're proposing so this
connected word in there is too much it's
not connected at all he's trying to
connect it with abstract concepts and
that's not a connection
anyways he's not the only one who's uh
you know he's who's trying to make money
uh all these people also you know not
only harming but cox alkali all these
people they're just trying to make money
none of these are scientists none of
these are physicists
they are all diluted um charlatans
that's what they are and they're making
money that's their only purpose that's
why they're up there and they're
supported by the establishment okay
because it keeps the ball rolling
and so they just pass on what they learn
in in college by rote through authority
through tradition and they pass that on
down to the masses
and what they do is really entertainment
they don't do physics they do
entertainment okay so
you know that's that's the world in
which we live that's that's what
so-called physics you know mathematical
physics mathematics that's what it's uh
evolved into that's how it developed
that's what we have today
and for the last 60 years there hasn't
been anything new
you know in quantum
nothing change they still have particles
uh they want to call these particles no
longer they call them particles like
discrete particles nothing like that now
they're called fields and a particle is
really
a an excited field locally and when you
measure it then you measure it as a
particle when you don't measure it you
don't look at it you don't see it you
don't touch it then it becomes a field
back again
so that's the way they treat that
how about uh general relativity well uh
in the 60s you had uh roger penrose and
stephen hawking and they popularized uh
a thought that had already been coming
from 1915 which was the black hole they
popularized the black hole well when
people got tired of that in the i think
it towards the end of the
80s or 90s i think it was 98 i think in
98 they came up with dark matter you
know i never heard of that uh that came
much later
and uh so today we have dark matter and
since then there's been nothing new it's
all the same nonsense they just
regurgitate all these people they say
exactly the same thing you saw one you
heard one you heard them all
there's no difference between any of
these people maybe one guy says it a
little differently than the other gives
you a different example different
analogy fine you know they're a little
different in that sense but they all say
you know the bottom line when you
you know open the onion all the way to
the end
they all say the same thing and it's uh
black holes dark matter until you get
sick of it okay uh dark energy obviously
you know uh parallel universes big bang
you're going to hear that
about all that till the end of time
quantum mechanics same nonsense
particles it can be at two places at
once you have entanglement you have
superposition the same old nonsense they
all say the same thing you see one
you're seeing them all so there's
nothing new and in that sense you could
say physics mathematical physics is that
a dead end what more equations do we
need we need to figure out how gravity
works we need to figure out you know how
this uh magnet attracts that one okay
that's what we need to figure out that's
what people want to understand that's
what people want to do
and we don't have that after 3000 years
or maybe more you know nobody
understands that yet nobody can
in mathematics okay mathematical physic
can explain to you how magnet attracts
another
or or
how gravity works
okay
uh fellow says in relation to that he's
uh two two
fellows and this gives you um an idea of
what the state of a lot of people is out
there they become
atheists in mathematical physics they
don't like all that garbage they hear
about big bang and uh black holes and
dark matter they don't understand any of
it they they hear the same thing over
and over they want to search for
clues for how this universe works and
they can't find it they can't find it
out there in mathematical physics the
official version right and so these two
fellows one says science is a religious
thing it's been used to replace the
divining
the
future by inspecting chicken and
your mission is to find a replacement
that fulfills that function yeah sounds
a religion we've been doing that for a
while it's all magic and bs okay and
another thought says scientists don't
know nothing
neither does anyone else
you know people have lost hope and they
say you know it's all nonsense these
what are these people feeding us
and you know these are usually laymen
and they don't understand anything
what's going on out there and they can't
get an understanding
maybe they're trying to find something
they're trying to find out how this
universe works how does gravity work how
does magnetism work electricity and so
on light
and these people just keep giving in the
run around mathematical equations and so
on so they're sick of all that okay
and here's another fella he says
something along those lines he
criticizes me and that's good i like to
put these people up here okay
ah i fell on the other side
but i don't have one problem i have the
other give me a second here let me get
it up there again
okay here it goes if i get it right
okay he says we are all in the same boat
bill
uh-huh
even you as we fight the stupid
establishment okay
your rope hypothesis will only be
contemplated by flat earthers
and i guess he meant also the electric
universes
no serious scientists will ever respond
to any of your work they have vested
interest in what is said to be
now
flat earthers can think outside the box
no doubt about that just like the
electric universe people can okay
stop talking down to the people that try
to learn you are doing
you are going to need them
well what can i say i say that you know
i don't need these people i don't need
them because not because the
establishment is irrational i'm gonna go
with more irrationality coming out of
the flat earthers and the electric
universe and the uh
john chappelle society also another
group there
all these groups are irrational they
don't have anything rational in them so
it's not like i'm gonna
say okay i'm gonna
unite with all my enemy with the enemies
of my enemies you know it doesn't work
that way in science in science i'm for
myself okay it's like the three
stooges you know say oh for one one for
all imitating at the uh the uh
the uh
what is it the
three musketeers and cody says i'm for
myself and i'm for myself okay i'm like
curly okay yeah i don't i don't take uh
i i don't
take all these bs from all these people
from electric universers and flat
earthers just because you know i'm
fighting the establishment okay i'm
fighting the establishment but i do it
on my own i don't need these people
certainly i don't want to be associated
with them and here's a reason why here's
the electric universe okay
it's irrational completely gravity they
say is electricity absolutely nonsense
uh in that sense the establishment has
it correctly uh gravity is gravity it's
not electricity and electricity has
nothing to do with gravity and vice
versa
they can't define electricity i did a
little bit of that last time here it is
real quick okay
uh you go to the thunderbolts and they
say what is electricity and it says it's
a catch-all term that describes several
different phenomena but uh phil says
consensus opinion is lacking precision
reducing electric terminology into
smaller units is impossible because why
it lies at the bottom of the lexical
well in other words he says it's just
semantics okay and then he says
electricity which we define as the flow
of electric charge
particles of charge but then he has the
flow it's traveling you know travels
through the circuit and he says
electromagnetic energy flows and
electricity moves through the dc circuit
so if electricity is the flow or
whatever now we have the flow of flow
that's moving and here you have uh what
it is really uh it's a river you know
that's what electricity is
according to these people and if it's
the river river has two components okay
and what are they well they you have the
flow and you have the water so you can
say the water flows
okay
and that's what a river is but you
cannot say the river flows not in
physics you can do that in ordinary
speech but not in physics in physics you
have to name the object in this case
it's the water and you can say river is
water plus flow okay so now we
understand that that's what electricity
is according to the electric universe
but see they say
um
electricity is it's either the flow or
the water which one is electricity
and no electricity is both because
electricity is like a river according to
the establishment and according to the
electric universe okay so flow of
particles so either you can say the
particle flows
in electricity is the particle or
electricity is the flow or electricity
is the particle flows
okay in that sense electricity is a
river but then the object the thing that
is flowing is the particle
okay so let's not lose sight of that
the particle is what is flowing that's
what we're going to concentrate on we
want to know what the physical object
that is flowing is and of course they
can't do that because they can't even
start with their atom they don't have an
atom in the electric universe
they still use um
neil bohr
niels bohr and
rutherford's atom planetary atom you
know the little uh proton and the little
uh electron flowing around
and the only question they got to answer
before they talk about electricity is
why doesn't the little electron fall
to the nucleus to the proton why doesn't
it spontaneously fly away
in fact uh that was what triggered
quantum mechanics the fact that they
could not explain
why the electron doesn't spiral into the
nucleus that's what started quantum
mechanics and to this day we still have
no answer to that
the only answer that mr boar gave he
says look the little bead falls between
energy levels back and forth these
regions right and it doesn't fall all
the way to the nucleus just falls to the
lower energy level then it rises to the
energy to the upper energy level and
it's within these
orbitals what is an orbital a concept
it's just a region we want to know if
it's a wall in fact it's got to be a
wall
one for it to prevent it from flying out
and the other one from flying in right
it's two nested walls
uh spherical walls that encapsulate the
proton we can understand that but then
the question would be why does the
little bead go back and forth jumping
between these two walls then you can
more or less conceptualize what the atom
looks like that's not what these people
are saying they're saying we have two
regions and the electron just goes back
and forth between these two regions we
don't know why it doesn't fall to the
nucleus we don't know why it doesn't fly
out of the solar system you know or out
of whatever to the other side of the
universe
we have no idea from quantum mechanics
okay so the
electric universe invokes the
planetary model which is absolute
nonsense and until they can get an atom
they can't even talk about electricity
let alone the fact that they can't
define it and and tell us that it's the
flow of flows okay and all that stuff
uh they build their continuous filaments
with this discrete atom
you know they talk about the universe
also somewhat being interconnected with
all these filaments well again it's one
way electron flow
and that's how they plan to connect
everything you know bind everything
pull i guess i don't know and the
question there is also if um
electricity flows from you know the
negative pole to the positive flow you
have all these electrons negative
electrons flowing to the positive pole
which uh star is the positive which
one's the negative you know do they
switch back and forth alternating
current i mean
a lot of questions that these people
don't answer
uh they treat plasma as a physical
object plasma is not a physical object
under any definition
whether it's the uh forced state of
matter there's no physical object
standalone object called force state of
matter so that already eliminates so
never use that definition for to say
that plasma is a four state of matter
because you lost already you don't even
realize it there's no physical object
called four state of matter so you
cannot say plasma is the fourth state of
matter and then it's also an object a
thing okay so that's the first thing
they don't understand and they say well
you're doing semantics now it's called
physics laying the foundations of
physics you have to start with language
so that we can communicate okay you
can't say well i don't care about
semantics i came here to do physic
that's the way these people think or
don't
and uh then the other issues that plasma
is uh is a dynamic
concept it's not even a physical object
it's a dynamic concept and again we have
the flowing river
you know um is the river
the water the flow or the flow of water
is it both and plasma is uh
uh
an atom that's been ionized
ionized is a verb not an ad you could
use it as an adjective
in fact we use it as an adjective
adverb really because
it's a qualifying motion ionized means
you're going to remove
according to the establishment according
to the electric universe you're going to
remove an electron
from an atom so you're pulling something
out that's not a physical object you
can't say i pulled a banana out of the
pile
and that putting a banana is a physical
object
and that's what plasma is the plasma is
pull an electron from an atom that's not
a physical object you can say the
electron is a physical object you can
say the atom is a physical object we can
accept that we cannot say that pulling
an electron is a standalone physical
object okay plasma is a dynamic concept
so you can't say plasma does this and
plasma does that because it's already
doing it before you even mention the
word
so it's neither a the fourth state of
matter is not a physical object and
pulling an electron is not a physical
object okay
in both cases we have verbs
okay uh they also use the um ether the
vortex nonsense uh
a lot of them not everybody okay uh they
introduce mathematical physics jargon
just casually you know here they
criticize the establishment then they go
out there and borrow all their words
charge uh field wave they use all these
words you know none of them are physical
objects you can't use any of those words
in science not in physics you can use
them in mathematics in a religion of
mathematics you can say oh it's a field
oh it's a wave
oh it's a charge
you can't use those words in science
okay those are concepts you can't say
that charge is a standalone physical
object no charge is 1.6 times 10 to the
minus 19 coulombs that's what charge
it's a number
and a wave is what is a
standing thing no you can say water
waves flag waves what's the object flag
what's the object water
so when you see the electromagnetic wave
what is it that it's waving
and some people say nothing is waving
that it doesn't need a medium for it to
be wavy
then how can you conceptualize the
waving of nothing what is waving space
like uh
harem said
space is what's waving nothing is waving
please draw it
okay
and so you can't use that uh that
language that these people have borrowed
from mathematical physics
uh name proposed experiments we don't do
experiments in science yeah just like
you heard let me repeat it just in case
you say what was the slip of the tongue
no we don't do experiments in science
is that clear
we explain experiments we explain
observations we don't gawk and say oh i
did an experiment i'm a scientist oh i i
observed i'm a scientist no the fact
that you uh you know drooled and gawked
you know
doesn't make you a scientist it's when
you come to the conference and you
explain
the results you know what you learned
then then you're a scientist but to say
that you did an experiment you know here
i do experiments all the time i let the
spoon let go of it and it falls to the
ground
does that make me a scientist because i
just did an experiment oh sorry i got to
do it repeatable two times at least okay
so it's a repeatable experiment there
i'm a scientist
now we don't do experiments gophers do
uh experiments in fact
where i worked in the fabs a lot of
operators did the experiments for us
we collected the data we had to analyze
the data that's where the scientist
intervenes but
to do an experiment a lot of people can
do experiments just need hands and eyes
for that sometimes not even eyes anyways
uh and uh one thing that they have is
that the electric universe they censor
critics in this sense they get a little
bit they give out a little bit of the
medicine that they uh take they they
hate the establishment because the
establishment
uh censors them and they do the same
thing to everybody else so once these
organizations are built up they do
censorship as well
so that's the story for mr haramein uh
is simply a businessman who uh put a
little shop over there and i think it's
honolulu he's in hawaii
and what he tries to do is uh he's
diversified he's got lots of line items
there but the one he's trying to push
because that's his lineup that's what he
studied mathematics right he's trying to
convince the establishment that he's got
something new and that he can help with
all this string theory and uh
and the understanding of how this
universe works especially gravity uh by
saying that a proton is just a tiny
black hole and he's gonna
fall into this black hole and he's gonna
try to map it against the inside you
know the
event horizon he's going to map whatever
garbage fell into the black hole right
and no one addresses the
key issue which is a black hole is
nothing zero dimensional as proven by mr
chandrasekhar for which he won the nobel
prize therefore there's nothing there
and if you have no matter you have no
mass or black hole also has no mass no
size no nothing black hole is the
definition of
nothing okay of empty space
okay let's move on to uh
general relativity okay here we have uh
uh the starting point very
straightforward okay
general relativity says that gravity is
the warpage of time
bending of time that's what they say is
gravity
okay so here it is illustrated for you
okay we have the seconds
and the reason the earth doesn't fly out
of the solar system
is because there's a wall
of seconds a wall of minutes a well of
years maybe decades centuries that
prevents the earth from flying out of
there okay i did it with seconds because
i don't really know which unit they're
using okay
so all i can tell you is that this is
what general relativity says
says that time is warped okay there's uh
this four dimensional entity one of the
legs of that entity is known as time
it's measured in seconds it's a
you could say a parameter that is very
important to mathematical physics and
what they do they bend this time they
call it a dimension dimension right
and this bent dimension apparently
serves as a wall to the earth so the
earth doesn't fly out of the solar
system because the seconds are warped
okay
actually that's not totally totally true
because it comes from einstein's
equation okay
and
einstein's equation is a field equation
let me remove this here
it's a field equation okay
what is a field well as we saw a minute
ago a field is just a bunch of numbers
it's a set of numbers
and would in the case of gravity but
really all fields for that matter all
they're talking about is that numbers
decrease
or you could say
the force
becomes weaker
the farther you get away from ground
zero
that's the notion of a field it's a
bunch of numbers a set of numbers
spherical uh
shell
you know encapsulating ground zero right
so it's a spherical shell of different
strengths of whatever of electricity
magnetism gravity so the farther away
you get from ground zero from the center
point whatever it is could be the earth
for gravity it could be the earth for
magnetism and so on it could be a charge
you know a little
stick of electricity and from there
electricity magnetism
gravity all decreases in strength as you
get farther away so a field is just a
bunch of numbers
that they can measure they say well the
field strength here is so much and over
here farther out it's weaker and closer
to the thing it's stronger that's what a
field is
okay so here it is uh let's put that
same thing
uh first let's find out what the
definition of field is again here we
have field a quantity okay
represented by a number that has a value
for each point in space and time
so it is a field it's a quantity it's a
number okay
it's a represented by a number that has
value determine all numbers right
amounts quantities right for each point
location okay
um in space and time
so that's what a field is
and uh so the question here is you know
that's you see it there illustrated
that's what a field is a bunch of
numbers they get weaker and weaker by
illustrated here becoming smaller and
smaller okay
that's what that's what a field is a
bunch of numbers surrounding an object
that's that's what it is whether you
talk about a gravitational field electro
electric field or magnetic field that's
what a field is
okay so um let's uh let's illustrate
this with the earth let's find out what
prevents the earth from flying out i
said a minute ago that it was
uh time you know you've got warpage of
time could be
the seconds are warped and they turn
these things into physical objects
these words right they turn them into
physical objects
and here you have it
here's the uh field
also around the earth okay so the earth
goes around
and what you have is these numbers and
they're vibrating because the fields is
you know vibrating numbers they they
uh wiggle back and forth they up and
down in different directions okay so
it's not like the uh earth just goes
around and circles around nothing right
uh or on top of nothing there is
something there and they call it a field
and so the first question you should ask
yourself is hold it how does field uh
what does field have to do with time
because if on the one hand you have time
serving as a wall as a
dimension that is curved around and
prevents the earth from flying out
because they're saying it's warped space
time time right that prevents the earth
from flying outwards then how does a
field which is a bunch of numbers
uh that just decrease in strength from
ground zero how does one thing have
anything to do with the other
you know how do you reconcile field with
time that's the question
okay because uh
field is it's just a bunch of numbers
that
are weaker
as you get out right from say the sun in
this case the sun is the center of
our system here we're talking about the
sun and the earth right the center of
the sun
is where the great uh
uh biggest uh point for the field is the
strongest point and as you get out it
gets weaker and weaker and weaker all
the way to the earth okay so again so
the gravitational field gets weaker as
it gets farther away from the sun until
you get to the earth and even weaker as
you get farther out
great
what does that have to do with the wall
of time warp
work space time right
that serves as the depression along
which the earth rolls around like a
little ball on the roulette
that's the question so what does field
have to do with time which one is the
true mechanism they say einstein's is a
field theory
and then on the other hand they say time
warp time is what prevents the earth
from flying out
so you know you try to make sense of
that i don't think you can make sense of
either one of them but
putting you know they seem like
they're contradicting each other
okay in order to get to how do we come
up with all this nonsense general
relativity poppycock uh well we gotta
start all the way to newton 17th century
okay so let's bring mr newton in and he
came up with an equation really he
wasn't the originator of the equation it
was the french who later on developed
the equation he's given the credit
because he's the guy who said mass mass
divided by distance squared in other
words you have two masses two objects
and we're looking at the weight the mass
of each one right
and uh it's inversely proportional to
the
uh square of the distance that's that's
essentially what newton said uh he
didn't even have the gravitational
constant g
at the time okay he just said look uh
there's this inverse relation to
distance okay
uh between the masses okay and so this
is what it looks like okay here's newt's
equation says force equals gravitational
constant g mass mass
multiply those divided by distance
square and that gives you the full
gravitational force okay two masses
separated by distance
the big problem is he said hypothesis
nonfingo he wrote in latin okay they did
in those days that was the english of
those days everybody who was educated
would talk or write in latin
turns out he says hypothesis num fingo
meaning
he doesn't have any theory he doesn't
have an explanation for how that works
okay what he had is a description
mathematical description but not
uh but not a theory he did not have an
explanation of physical interpretation
of how gravity works and to this day no
one in mathematical physics has one and
he was a particle man he believed in the
ether also and so you know he could not
imagine how particles going out from the
earth and going up from the sun could
attract one another so he said you know
he he couldn't explain this he said you
know i i have no
no explanation for how this works and
here's
his words
and they come from the principia and
from a letter he sent to uh bentley okay
and the first one he says in the letter
of bentley says that gravity should be
essential to matter so that one body may
act upon another at a distance through a
vacuum without the mediation of anything
else
okay without a mediator right by and
through which their action and force may
be conveyed from one to another is to me
so great an absurdity that i believe no
man who has competent faculty of
thinking can ever fall into it
he continues says gravity must be caused
by an agent acting constantly according
to certain laws
okay so there's got to be a mediator an
agent okay he said there's got to be
something in there okay what was the
problem he couldn't see or touch
anything between two atoms
or between two objects so he says
gravity must be caused by an agent
acting constantly according to certain
laws but whether this agent is material
or immaterial i have left open to the
consideration of my readers
so he says i have no theory
i'll let you figure it out you come up
with whatever you want but i'm just
going to describe essentially in other
words he was not a theorist all he was
is a mathematician what do
mathematicians do well they describe
they can only describe that's all that
mathematics can do it cannot explain
anything and that's why newton could not
explain a single thing
and then he continued in precipitation
and this is the version of 1713 he also
wrote in 1687 i have not as yet been
able to discover the reason for these
properties of gravity from phenomena and
i do not feign hypothesis again
no fingernail hypothesis right
and this hypothesis whether metaphysical
or physical listen to this whether of
all uh
qualities or mechanical have no place in
experimental philosophy meaning
mathematics okay
so
here you can see his what happened in
the 17th century so-called scientific
revolution they said look we don't care
about the explanation we don't care
about the physical interpretation
we don't care about any of that what we
care about is experimental experiments
right experimental philosophy he said we
care about experiments we care about
describing them mathematically and
that's it measurement but he had no
explanation he said well we don't care
about that okay he said it is enough
that gravity does really exist and act
according to the laws which we have
explained now you haven't explained
anything to it you've only described
explanation means that you can explain
give us a physical interpretation right
of the causes and mechanism and
obviously he was not able to do that
and so he says uh that all he can do is
uh describe essentially the motions of
the celestial objects and the sea etc so
all that newt could do was describe okay
that was that was his f uh folly he says
look all i can do is describe
and he called it an explanation which it
wasn't to this day we have no
explanation fourth coming from the
establishment mathematical establishment
and i recommend that you do not hold
your breath okay okay um just in case
you know he used particles and particles
can only push
but even if you replace them with like
robert hook's
waves right uh he's the guy who came up
first with the longitudinal waves later
they were
converted into transverse waves by uh
in 19 the early 19th century
folks okay
and uh fresnel and fizzo and some of
these other frenchmen there
and here um here you see what uh what
happens with a wave wave only pushes
okay there is no wave that attracts you
cannot attract with a wave wave can only
push so whether you use particles or
waves you're going to be pushing okay
and so the question is how do you
produce pull with push
okay
and that's when mr einstein comes in he
changed a little bit
quite a bit you know the physical
interpretation of gravity and he got rid
of newton he said look this thing that
you got force particles
waves none of those work really
we do it differently in general
relativity how do they do it they said
he said
he did it with this
field this
supposedly
medium that pervades everything in the
universe in other words space is itself
a physical medium in general relativity
they call it space-time before then they
call it the ether the same nonsense just
different words essentially he says
there's this medium
this medium is made of particles
just like the ether is no different
and uh and and what are those particles
they're really locations
of where you're going to measure
something okay and that's where quantum
uh intersects you could say with uh
general relativity with space time
okay so here's uh einstein he changed
that he's gonna do it with push but it's
uh listen to how he does his push
gravity he does it a little differently
than uh newton newton drew particles
back and forth he says i can't explain
it with that how does einstein explain
and here it gives you an idea
he's got this equation
left-hand side is space-time curvature
right-hand side is the source in other
words the source in this case bends
space time downwards base it's bending
time downwards and because of that uh
space time is warped and that forces the
moon to roll around the earth okay so
that's essentially the physical
interpretation we do not care at all
about einstein's equation he can do all
the equations he wants when he comes
into physics he's got to explain how
gravity works and this is his
explanation this is the explanation of
relativity and we take it literally we
don't take it as an analogy at all it
either is or it ain't you can't say this
is just an analogy now if it's an
analogy an analogy of what if you're
going to later on say well i deny all
this uh there the there is no depression
there is no moon going around this
depression and the earth doesn't push
uh
a canvas downwards then what was the
purpose of the analogy if you're later
on going to deny it either this is or
that it ain't
and you have a statement from mr wheeler
john wheeler who sympathizes as space
time tells matter how to move matter
tells space time how to curve that's
essentially what the equation says
that's what it tells us
okay
okay what happened was that well you
have um uh
all the mathematicians this was in 1915
when einstein came up with his field
equation and all the mathematicians you
know well not all but in fact very few
at the first uh did not like uh
did like his idea said it's different
why they liked it because suddenly they
had a different physical interpretation
for how gravity works and that's great
if you've got a better interpretation
let's look at it you know and
one of the things that eventually came
out is that
einstein's equation was a little more
accurate than newton's especially when
they had to de uh describe the orbit of
mercury okay
whereas newton has two masses separated
by distance in this case uh mercury and
the sun
einstein's equation what they did the
field equations what they did was they
looked at a point mass that's going
around the sun
around so we have a point mass going
around another mass that's all they
looked at they don't look at objects
they don't look at things they say that
we have a point mass going around and
what einstein's equation does is
describe it describes the itinerary
of that little
point mass
and so it turns out that perihelion
mercury's perihelion
uh ship
let's say this right mercury's
perihelion would shift over time it
would you know
shift uh and uh formed like a rosetta
over
uh
many orbits and because of that you know
they weren't able to explain that with
newton's equation they were able to
explain it a little or describe it
really with einstein's equation and so
they said well einstein's equation is a
little more accurate than newton it's a
little closer it wasn't perfect either
but it got closer a lot of people say
that he fudged the numbers to get him
closer fine that's you know opinions
there but the point is that the
mathematicians later on when they
finally bought into his theory his
description his uh
uh equation field equation uh all the
the reason is the main reason was that
or one of the main reasons was that it
was more accurate than newton's okay and
here so here's an analogy okay here we
have two mathematicians mathematician a
he comes up with an equation and he says
look
i measured i did this i did my
calculations and he ends up with a
straight line that's his equation
describes a straight line
another
mathematician you know he's a little
uh more sophisticated maybe and he goes
in there he measures he does his
calculation he says well it's not quite
a straight line i think it's like a
curvature
so now he gets the nobel prize why
because he's got a more accurate
equation that
uh reflects
what they've been studying
but see
all they're doing is uh uh
ad hoc stuff they're tailoring the
equations to their measurements and once
they discover and
that the measurement is not exactly the
what they thought it was and they
perfect the measurement they say oh we
made an advance
and all they're doing is tailoring the
math to what they observe
so
mathematics you know mathematics is a
tactology as as it's applied to
mathematic mathematical physics it's a
tautology all they do is measure and
come up with an equation and once they
have that equation boy it had better
meet you know they say we can predict of
course you can predict you can predict
because you did it a hundred times
you finally get tweaked the equation to
the point where it matches exactly and
now you can say oh we can predict
and so what you still haven't explained
anything you haven't explained the cause
of gravity you haven't explained the
cause of magnetism but you can predict
that a magnet attracts another or that
you know this spoon will fall to the
table great you can predict and you can
tell me exactly how fast and what the
acceleration is and get all the numbers
right
but you still cannot tell me what the
cause of gravity is
okay and so that's where we stand today
and that's what they dismiss as
philosophy
okay
um
here we have um
one of the things that einstein
apparently explained and it's the
mercury helium shift you can see that
the
orbit is shifting over time that's more
or less what's happening with uh
mercury's
uh perihelion
and they thought it there was originally
they thought aliberrier was one of the
fellows a french guy who discovered
neptune
he thought oh same thing we have a
planet there somewhere between the uh
mercury and the sun
and they called it vulcan and they were
looking for this planet over decades
they finally gave up they said there is
no plant there we can't find it no
matter what we do
and
einstein came up with his equation and
said oh i can explain it in other words
describe it i can describe the orbit
of mercury better than newton and with
that they said okay
now we like it because not only could
einstein describe it
the orbit better but he also
on top of that he was able to do a
second thing which was this here which
is
happened four years after his equation
he came up with his equation at the end
of uh 1915 and then by 1919 mr eddington
uh
head honcho over there in
england right mary old england and he
came up with this he was able to prove
einstein's
prediction that light curves around
the sun during an eclipse
and
so you know eddington
gave some kudos to einstein and the new
york times picked it up and from that
time einstein became a household word
okay
everybody knew einstein after that
because he had predicted the curvature
of the sun
of the i'm sorry the light around the
sun okay
okay but how does einstein do his uh
gravity well he he does it also through
push
okay but it's a funny way he does push
and here it is okay once you see this
this is how
gravity in general relativity is done
through push okay so how do you pull
with push here you'll see it okay first
you build this uh thing
a bowl and you push it down with that
green ball whatever that green ball so
it weighs it downwards so you so the
ball is weighing down it means it's
pushing
okay the uh
flexible the malleable
green ball downwards okay
and this uh
compels or
or in induces
uh something to go around the edge of
the bowl okay
and so what does that little thing do
the little red ball well it's pushing
outwards
so in both cases you have push you have
pushed downwards and pushed sideways and
the only reason einstein could get away
with it is that you have a continuous
bowl
okay so that was his insight the fact
that he's got a continuous object which
is the ball in this case but he's doing
it through push he pushes downwards and
outwards and that's how he's going to
explain gravity okay so it's important
to know that uh unlike newton who said
look you know we have uh
particles going back and forth you know
force
einstein said no no we have mass
weighing down right
uh
meaning it's going to push
the canvas downwards and the other one's
gonna push towards the side of the bowl
just like a roulette you know but then
the issue is you know why does the green
ball you know push downwards what's
you know so uh good old line size
invoking gravity
force right newton's force newton's
gravity to explain gravity okay that's
what he's doing he's saying gravity is
like this look we have a force
to start out with that pushes the canvas
downwards
okay that's push
and then the other one has no other
choice but to roll around why it's so
why does it fall inside the hole well we
don't know you know it just keeps
rolling around forever and of course you
cannot explain this with a three-body
system you can only explain with two
okay that's another issue
okay and because of that you have you
know these people who say that you know
you have all these ripples these waves
that go along
space time and they say those cannot
travel faster than the speed of light
because the speed of light is the limit
the speed limit of the universe and so
no wave can travel faster
and they have the but a wave travels one
way also
so they discovered a few years ago a
couple years ago they discovered uh
gravitational waves from two black holes
that allegedly collided they got an oval
for all that stuff and the question is
you know
that wave comes one way so let's assume
two black holes collide lots of mass
gray let's concede all that
so two black holes heavy as the entire
universe they collide and they create
waves great these waves come towards us
how does that produce attraction towards
the two black holes
that's that's what we have no idea
of and so here you have uh because the
mathematicians say look when if the sun
were to disappear
uh you know these gravitational waves
they can't travel faster than light so
we would not fly out immediately from
the solar system us being the earth
right we would not fly out instantly it
would take eight minutes
for all those waves to travel to
the earth a long
space time
so here you're rolling around time right
because time doesn't is curved and does
not allow the earth to fly outwards
right time is curved there and here you
have these waves
that come along space time i guess time
is all the way to the earth to the sun
and they come along they're now faster
than the speed of light and until
you know that sun disappears and there's
no mass
weighing down the canvas we don't fly
out and this is an illustration of that
here you see it okay
so
according to relativity if the sun were
to disappear
it would take eight minutes for the
earth to fly out of the solar system
because gravity cannot travel faster
than light
okay so this is the notion that we have
today and there you have space time all
those uh that canvas there you know that
space and you can see the waves coming
towards the earth okay but what's the
issue the issue is that
uh they treat space and time as physical
objects meaning time is a physical
object because it's one of the legs of
space-time four-dimensional space time
okay and so well there you have it
that's that's the
that's the um
party line that's what you will learn if
you go to
uh the university and uh
now you're an expert in uh general
relativity there's no more than that for
the theory for the explanation for the
physical interpretation we don't care
about the math they can do all the math
they want when they come to the
conference we want to explain
the physical mechanism
okay and uh so we don't need to curve
space time okay
uh like mr eddington did you know with
the light moving around the sun and
here's a comparison between what he did
and how we do it under the rope model
okay
according to him light curves around the
sun so we have star
in far away
and
that light from that star curves around
the corona of the sun okay that's the
way einstein saw it why does it curve
because it follows the curved path of
space time
meaning time is a physical object time
is curved and light travels along or
slides along rolls along i don't know
along this curved
path of time
how do we do it well we do it a little
differently we do it all with straight
lines we say that uh light is mediated
by a rope which is under tension between
any two atoms
so it's always uh taut that rope is
always taut okay and what happens is
that uh light propagates along this rope
from one atom to the next and from the
star very far away to an atom that forms
the corona of the sun
it is relayed from that uh star from
that from that atom that's
uh doing its quantum jump it's relayed
from there to the earth in other words
you do it all with straight lines you
have one straight line from an atom in
the star to an atom that forms a corona
of the sun and that's uh star that atom
is uh titillating you know it's um
it's uh expanding and contracting doing
its quantum jump and from there it
relays that same impulse all the way to
your eye and that's why we see it so we
do it all with straight lines no
curvature
uh light never curves only only after 10
uh beers it might curve you know but
otherwise i don't think so okay so uh
what do we have um
let's let's compare
here we're going to compare uh uh what
general relativity proposes it's got
this canvas
which is space-time supposedly
four-dimensional they put it in a
three-dimensional version because they
cannot illustrate what they're talking
about and you have to accept it as is
and here's the rope model of the same
thing okay
here you see it we say that all atoms of
the sun are interconnected with all
atoms of the earth and the sun
essentially
uh swings the earth around itself
uh
by these ropes that can uh connect
physically connect every single atom of
both objects okay so that's it you can
get an idea
from there how easy it is uh the reason
the earth doesn't slow down
significantly at least it's because um
space is nothing so the earth has no way
of rubbing its uh elbow against the
space because there's nothing there
space is nothing it's not a thing like
in
relativity okay
in relativity space is a physical object
it's the ether they call it space-time
they give it four dimensions they say
it's unimaginable they go through all
this rigmarole
uh
in in under rope it's very simple it's
just the ropes connecting every atom and
there is no such thing as space space is
nothing and so the earth has no friction
with space and that's why it rolls
around forever
pretty much unless there are other
uh
objects
okay that are affecting the earth like
you know other planets and other things
that are out there in space
okay you say where did you get this
notion bill that you know we're
interconnected that
the earth is connected to the sun that
the um
what is it that the moon is connected to
the earth well i showed this the other
day i'm going to show it one more time
if you listen carefully maybe you
learned something okay here it goes okay
this is mr brian green and he's going to
tell us how the moon is connected to the
earth
how does gravity actually work
how does the earth pull on the moon
across hundreds of thousands of miles of
empty space they behave as if they're
connected by some kind of invisible rope
but everyone knew that wasn't true
okay so what did mr green say says that
it's like if
as if we're connected to the moon by an
invisible robe but that obviously cannot
be so
why because they had the wrong
definition or an irrational definition
which they still have of the word object
they think an object is that which you
can see or touch so they go to the lab
and they say let's run an experiment to
see and touch the mediator of gravity
the mediator of magnetism now you can't
do that you can't touch see or touch the
mediators that mother nature uses
they're invisible intangible yes there
are invisible intangible objects numena
that we talked about a couple weeks ago
yeah uh these new men are uh they're uh
invisible intangible objects and they're
uh uh like um was it um
uh
well one of the so-called philosophers
uh said you know lumena are um
are objects of the mind in other words
you have to visualize them you have to
imagine them you can't go there and see
and touch them okay but if you make the
assumption that those invisible
intangible objects mediators are there
then you can explain the universe very
easily it's only when you do black magic
and you say everything is action at a
distance entanglement uh
the gluon connected that connects uh two
quarks they do it all what through
action at a distance and uh gravity you
know you have all these action at a
distance
and yeah if you're gonna do action at a
distance you're doing black magic okay
okay so um
here you have another testimony of why
how everything is interconnected i
showed this
last time as well so here it goes one
more time pay attention here you have mr
richard muller from berkeley and he
tells you how it is
what's the force of gravity on me
it's the pull of the earth
on my body
so for example if you have the earth
with its big mass here and then and you
have you
with your little mass here
that every atom on the earth
is pulling on every atom of you
you're also pulling on it
on the other hand there's a lot of atoms
here you're pulling on you're pulling on
all of them amazing thing about gravity
is it goes right through things
okay so
we're all connected every atom in the
universe is connected to all other atoms
you're connected to every atom on earth
physically otherwise you wouldn't be
pulling on every atom on earth and every
atom on earth wouldn't be pulling on
every atom of your body
and until you get that through your
thick skull
you're going to be doing
black magic because you're saying that
all these things happen through action
at a distance with no no mediator
why because you can't see or touch it
that's the whole issue that is the whole
issue once you concede
that mother nature works with invisible
intangible mediators
then you can understand how the universe
works and you forget about all the
nonsense that all these mathematicians
have been doing since the days of the
greek okay
okay
here's a
here's a situation you see this okay you
go out there in the middle of the field
and you see this okay
you see a fellow pulling on a donkey
but you can't see the mediator you're
too far away you say how is he pulling
on the donkey
is it black magic he just goes like this
and
the donkey comes towards him
okay so what are you going to use are
you going to use
stones
rocks
pebbles are you gonna throw
uh is that how you're gonna pull on the
donkey
you're gonna do it the
uh
uh
newtonian way you're gonna do it by
throwing stones at it force you're going
to push
stones in
to the face of the donkey and that's how
you pull them
and uh or are you going to do it maybe
with waves here's a different way of
doing it this is the wave
again the waves go outwards
how is it that you pull with waves which
is one of the ways that um
general relativity offers they say that
waves uh travel along space time so okay
so you have waves traveling at space
time let's concede all that let's grant
those hypothesis
so how does the fact that the wave goes
outward pull the donkey inwards
okay
now here's a fourth way that you can
ponder and that's using a rope
it's just pulled on the donkey now isn't
wasn't that so simple okay so you have
to decide you know what mechanism you're
going to use
to
produce gravity
and again the issue there is uh
you know what what is the physical
mediator
are you gonna use stones you know
particles are you gonna use waves are
you gonna use a rope
maybe the bowl that
einstein use you know the
canvas
and
there's another way and that's the
casimir way
and the casimir way is that you remove
particles between
the uh
puller and the donkey okay and this is
what you get okay you have uh this is
the casimir way
and what you have is yeah what you go in
there and remove the particles that
separate you from the donkey okay and
once you remove that you know what
happens is you have all these particles
from behind the donkey and behind you
and those pull you together that's the
casimir way and they call it casimir and
he came up with that in 1948 okay he
wrote a paper then but the idea already
came from reddicker and kramer and
lesage uh
he's also given uh great uh merits for
coming up with that but let's h got it
from fascio and fascio from blue crushes
so all these people already had that
idea of what is known as shadow gravity
or shadow pull where you remove
whatever's between them and whatever's
outside them pushes them together that's
the notion that casimir came up with in
his great mind you know
yeah and that's what they use today
instead of saying look there's a
physical object that's pulling they're
saying no we do a different way we
remove whatever in between and you know
the two objects come together
okay so that's in a nutshell general
relativity what is it essentially
it's a platform
made means the
space space time time whichever one you
want there's this ether out there that
they call space-time in the case of
general relativity it's a mathematical
contraption which is four dimensional
which is not really four dimensional
what it is is four number lined okay
because
mathematics doesn't have dimensions at
all or coordinates or vectors what they
have is number lines everything is has
magnitude and what they don't have is
direction okay or perpendicularity
orthogonality okay and a dimension is
exactly the opposite it has
orthogonality and direction what it
doesn't have you know length width and
height what they don't have is magnitude
at all
okay so uh
that's essentially you know what uh four
dimensional space time is
the
gravitational
mechanism is that you know you have
simply something weighing down the
canvas and the other object rolls around
you can't do it with three objects you
can only with two simulated with two
objects and then they tell you well the
analogy is worthless anyway so we don't
care about that all they care about is
the mathematics and so if you care about
understanding gravity and you want to
ask the question how does gravity work
you'll never find out from general
relativity because that's what they're
going to tell you and then they're going
to deny it at the end of the story and
say well you're not supposed to take the
analogy
so
literally that's the answer you get
okay we have our science critic and he
also analyzed uh general relativity and
so it's uh on topic today so let's see
what he had to say about general
relativity and space time specifically
here goes listen carefully
the questions and issues to be addressed
in this rebuttal include
does gps prove that general relativity
is correct
does space-time explain gravity
does space-time have anything at all to
do with physics
well it's not so much that we wouldn't
have developed gps if general relativity
was incorrect it's more that gps has to
account for general relativity because
otherwise it won't work and the
difference between these two statements
is that in the latter if general
relativity were false we could still
develop gps it just wouldn't have to
account for general relativity i know
that you do not believe in space time
but
the curvature of space time is the
mechanism that causes gravity to occur
or at least that is the best idea that
we currently have
the best idea the mathematicians have
that space time
and so the question one question with
gps is the gps prove
that time is a physical object that time
can be warped that time serves
as the wall that prevents the earth from
flying out of the solar system or the
moon for that matter
uh
and so that's the first question you
should ask is that a valid
physical interpretation does that make
any sense to you
and if they say well you're not supposed
to take the analogy so literally and we
don't care about physical
interpretations we just care about the
math
well then why are you asking
a question about mechanisms to a
mathematician first of all and second
why have they
ventured
into
what they call philosophy explaining the
mechanism why have they even attempted
that why don't they stay in math and say
look these are the equations
and they can stay there with their
description no problem it's when they
cross the line into physics and say look
our equations we interpret them as this
yeah but your interpretation is
ridiculous it's not even
worthy of consideration we have to lock
you up in a mental asylum if you come up
with that interpretation yeah well
you're not supposed to take it literally
well why didn't you why did you attempt
to do it in the first place
if if your physical interpretation is
garbage and you're going to reject it at
the end of your tale at the end of your
dissertation
why did you even attempt it why did you
even try why are you trying to give a
physical interpretation to begin with
well i'll tell you why because otherwise
mathematics you know mathematical
physics is worthless it's irrelevant if
they cannot give you a physical
interpretation
so they give you a description
then they give you their physical
interpretation their opinions which are
all ridiculous nonsense
and then they say forget about our
physical interpretations we know because
we do the equations every day and the
equations tell us
so they have is a measurement they have
a description they don't have an
explanation and this fellow believes
like so many people out there you know
they're they're fooled into believing
that
general relativity has an explanation
for gravity
a physical interpretation that you know
that uh warp space work time is what
prevents the earth from flying out of
the solar system they really believe
that they believe that space and time
are physical objects and again that's
the question does gps prove
that time is a physical object
and if it doesn't then gps is technology
and has nothing to do with science
it has nothing to do with science
science we have to explain okay we have
to explain why the gps little thingy
there rolls around the earth when
doesn't fly out of the solar system
what keeps gps you know the uh the probe
with the um
gyroscopes what keeps it rolling around
the earth why does it just keep rolling
out
is it going
around
another space-time depression
its own
dragging space time around itself as
they say
so here here's the problem with what
this file says you know
again we have time which is warped and
israel believes that it's these seconds
that serve as walls to the earth
we have time bent time work time curved
time
okay and that's what prevents the earth
from flying out of the solar system
that's the physical interpretation and
then they tell you well by the way don't
take it literally
then what have we learned if we're not
supposed to take this literally
that time is a concept that prevents the
earth a physical object from playing out
of the solar system
jesus christ
okay and uh so what's the problem the
problem is that time is not even a
dimension okay time is a number line
time time does not have direction
time only has magnitude and time doesn't
go perpendicular to anything because it
doesn't have direction on the other hand
length width and height in the case of
dimensions true dimensions
coordinates
longitude latitude altitude and vectors
like
you know depth breath and elevation all
these have perpendicular
and they have
direction what they lack all of these is
magnitude
and number lines have the opposite have
magnitude no direction no
perpendicularity that's why the
you know space-time four-dimensional
space-time is really for number lined
not for dimensional
okay
dementia is what mathematicians have
because they never define their terms so
they come up with nonsense as far as a
physical interpretation for what's
happening out there
that's the situation
okay we had uh some flat earthers okay
and uh they had all kinds of uh
problems understanding the question and
they still have problems understanding
the question they think they understood
the question they said but we answered
the question bill
and no you haven't you haven't even
understood the question so let's find
out what they don't understand and i'm
going to go through quickly through
these here's the first one paul says
on the other side give me a second here
here's the first one
says
during acceleration the air in the car
has a higher density in the back of the
vehicle than it does in the front
remember the balloon goes forward when
you accelerate instead of backward as
intuition would tell you and the idea is
that all this air that accumulates in
the back pushes the balloon forward so
the question was
why does the air go back or stay
in its place while the car accelerates
no one understands the question yet this
guy just says higher density in the bank
yeah we know that
you have to explain why there's higher
density in the bag okay it says this
means that the net force on the balloon
due to collisions with the ear will be
in the forward direction
yeah that's what happens when people
don't understand the question they just
repeat the same description they say
well
air goes back and pushes the balloon
forward yeah we know that
so please don't don't
answer the what hasn't been asked or
don't
answer with a description which we
already understand know and you know
have already put forth another fellow
says uh the balloon isn't pushed forward
without a roof on the car
so he's saying that it's the roof that
pushes the air right the car is the
container yeah we know that separating
the system off from the outside yeah we
know that too so it's isolated so the
motion of the container allows for the
accumulation inside the sealed container
and again it doesn't understand the
question the question is
why does the air accumulate in the back
you know when the car accelerates okay
it pushes the first few atoms or
molecules fine
and the question is why are the other
ones waiting
we're not concerned about the ones that
are being touched by the car the window
the roof we're concerned about the ones
that are standing still waiting for the
car to reach them
and i still didn't understand probably
okay but that's the best way i can
explain it to them the question i've
been this is five weeks now i've been
trying to explain the question
that's just um unbelievable
okay and um
same fellow says question what is the
mechanism to make air accumulate in the
back of the car yeah what that's the
question
do you understand the question no he
doesn't because he says the stretch of
the car and window does not allow air
molecules to transmit through it no kid
did you figure this out all by yourself
you must have had help i don't trust
people they get help it's a structure of
glass preventing an oxygen molecule from
passing through it
this is what they answer that air cannot
go through glass that's why
that's why it accumulates
okay same fellow he goes a little
further okay he says why does the air
monitor stay where it is yeah
that's what we want to
want you to answer okay says the
structure of the atmosphere where there
are trillions of other molecules holding
the total system in place
until a force disturbs it
physical mechanism structure of the
atmosphere similar to being in a child's
ball pit with
extremely tiny balls
so he's saying one of the two it's
either the glass of the back of the van
that's pushing the molecules forward or
that it's uh the other molecules that
are pushing
the molecules forward so he hasn't
answered he doesn't even understand the
question yet three times
he answered three times he never fixed
the problem he doesn't understand the
question this is five weeks that this
follows an understandable question
no the question is the question is he
asks the question but he doesn't
understand what he's asking what what
what the what the question is the
question why does the ear mole you stay
where it is okay so you have some
molecules that are being touched by the
car as the car accelerates
meanwhile
meanwhile meanwhile you have other
molecules that are waiting for either
the molecules or the core to smash
against them
why are those molecules that nothing has
touched them yet why are those standing
still why are they still in place why
haven't they moved
i mean they move a little bit we all
recognize that they move a little bit
but they don't move at the speed of the
car the car is squashing the molecules
that are closer to the window and
they're
pushing them all together so that's why
the density accumulates but until the
car runs we have some molecules which
are standing still or moving back some
people believe that they move back we're
going to argue here that they stand
still okay so we have molecules pushing
but some are standing still until
until
what they say a force no there is no
such thing as four no physical object
called force
until the back of the car or other
molecules of air
push them
okay but until that happens these
molecules are standing still
waiting for something to hit them
why are they standing still like a tree
stuck to the ground that's the question
five weeks now they still don't
understand the question and i'm not sure
they still understood it
yet you know
afl says couldn't it be the walls of the
car hitting the narrow on all sides same
thing these people are saying the the
the walls are hitting the volume now the
question why are the molecules standing
still until the wall hits them
okay so they they don't understand the
question it's unbelievable these people
are mentally [ __ ] they don't
understand the question
and uh and yeah they just have this
second nature that they say well
it is so the molecule's there until
something hits it a force they say a
force it could be a horse maybe man
that's what they're talking about there
is no physical object called force so
why these people use the word force i
have no idea there's no such thing as
force no such thing as density no
sensing is gravity okay you have to
identify the physical object that comes
in contact with
the molecule and it could be other
molecules it could be the glass or the
back of the van that we can accept you
can say the back of the van the wall the
glass hit the molecule that we all
understand and you can say other
molecules of air hit the molecule of air
that was standing still we can all
understand that as well the issue is
until until something hits it
why what keeps that molecule standing
still
and people think that will should stand
still until a force hits it and moves it
not true you have not justified that
you're just repeating
stuff that you don't understand okay
you're just saying it is so that's all
you're saying there is no reason for a
molecule to stand still
now in the case of the tree you say well
i know why that stands still because
it's stuck to the ground and on it's a
rigid entity essentially so that the
tree doesn't move with a car especially
if like i showed the uh a couple weeks
ago
you build the van on top of the
the tree so the tree is inside the van
right so it's inside the van it's not
touching any part of the van but when
the car or the van accelerates the tree
is left behind because it's stuck to the
ground even though it's inside the car
just like the molecule but the molecules
inside the car it also stands still just
like the tree
in the case of the tree you say well
it's because it's stuck to the ground so
is the molecule stuck to the ground also
that's the question so if else says the
question you're asking about why objects
stay behind is not related to the
container moving finally one person who
understands at least the question
yes the container has nothing to do with
the whole question so don't tell me the
container and don't tell me that the
molecules that have bundled up in the
back of here that they're going to push
the
molecule
forget about all that you have to tell
me why that molecule stands still until
something hits it that's the question if
we can if you can understand it why
don't the why doesn't the air
spontaneously moved to one side of the
container because the on average the
summation of random motion is zero so
this vowel is saying yeah it stands
still and it's got nothing to do with
the container okay great we understand
that that is you've got a little head
start over the other fellows okay but he
how does he answer he says the average
motion
that's not a question that that's not an
answer you can't say it's the average
motion that's mathematics we need to
know what physical object either keeps
the molecule in place until what other
other object hits it and moves it okay
so the question is why what causes
the molecule to stand still you're
making an assumption that it stands
still but you're not telling me what
causes it to stand still until something
hits it
and you just take it for granted it
stands still until something hits it not
true
absolutely not true nothing stands still
in the universe okay so you got to tell
me why it's standing still until
something hits it and if you take it for
granted you're making the wrong
assumption you're making an irrational
assumption okay
so that's the issue
okay so here we're going to illustrate
it one more time maybe someone
understands it finally okay here it is
here's the pencil okay and you can see
the pencil doesn't bunch up at the back
of the van
in other words all the atoms do not or
molecules they do not uh create higher
density in the back why you say well
it's because it's a rigid entity so all
the molecules all the atoms of the
pencil move at the same time okay
and again it's got nothing to do with
the uh
pencil going through the window like
some people say out there okay so you
can see the atoms are being pushed all
simultaneously and you say well because
it's a rigid
structure
that's why you say that's why they all
move forward at the same time okay but
here we did it with water the other day
okay we moved this rapidly water in a
container you can see that there's going
to be a gradient of water and it's going
to accumulate in the back there it is
okay very quickly you can see the water
moving towards the rear of the
container there and you can see there's
this gradient of water it all moved
backwards okay
so the question why did all that water
accumulate in the back
that's the first question but the real
question we want to understand is why
did water stand still the water
molecules until until the back of the
container hit it or other water
molecules hit it okay
that's going to be the question let's
see if we can understand the question
okay here it is illustrated okay we're
going to accelerate
the van okay
and you can see some molecules stay
until
something hits it until
something hits it the question is why
until something hits it does it stand
still okay why do
because we can all understand the back
of the van hitting molecules and piling
them up we can all understand that we
can all understand why molecules of air
are hitting other molecules of air and
bunching up those part we understand
that is not the question the question is
why do the ones that say stays why do
they stay
what keeps them in place is the question
okay
that's the question
i'm just trying to get people to
understand the question so let's stand
still let's
force this thing to stand still here it
is okay you can see the three molecules
in the back are standing are
are being bunched up
while the other ones are still in their
normal state essentially okay until
either a molecule of air or the back of
the truck hits it that molecule stays in
place
we want to understand why the molecule
stands in place what keeps it there and
don't tell me it stays there until
something hits it until there's a force
because it means you have to go to see a
shrink okay you've got mental problems
you're making an assumption that is
invalid okay so you cannot say the
molecule stands still because
no the everything is caused and standing
still
also is caused that's the issue okay
how do we explain it with a rope very
simple we explained this in the past
the molecule stands still because that
molecule is stuck to every atom on earth
every atom on earth is
stuck is pulling on that molecule that's
essentially the reason it stays more or
less in the same place until something
like the truck
hits it or another molecule set of
molecules air bunches up and pushes out
uh pushes the molecule forward okay and
here you have mr
muller again just in case so for example
if you have the earth there's a big mass
here and you have you with your little
mass here
every atom on earth is pulling on every
atom of you you're also pulling on in
please repeat this every night as your
prayer
uh every atom on earth okay
uh is pulling on every atom of you
you're also pulling on it
you have to memorize that mantra because
you're not understanding what this man
is telling you
okay
and until you understand that what are
you saying there every atom on earth is
pulling on every atom of you and you're
also pulling on it unless you understand
what that's telling you you won't
understand why that molecule stands
stays in place it stays in place because
every atom on earth is bound to that
atom and that atom is bound pulling on
every atom on earth so it more or less
stays in place that's what keeps it in
place
the assumption that you have in your
tiny little brain that until a force
pushes it stays there is irrational
that's what's irrational okay
and it takes a long time for these
mental cases to understand that flat
earthers
okay if al says according to your rope
hypothesis the air molecules are
connected to the container as well as
the rest of the universe yeah correct
when the container accelerates there
should be a small net force assuming
shorter roads have more effect and
longer ropes
no they don't
accelerating the air molecules in the
direction that the container travels
conventional science does not support
this yeah neither does a rope model
because again this first this individual
does not understand a rope model he
hasn't done a minimum of research here's
the our version
the atoms slide along a rope as the
they eat into the rope link by link
okay so an atom moves like a bead on an
abacus it slides without dragging the
rope behind it the ropes are always
tight taut they're pulled tightly
between any two atoms uh pulled by every
atom in the universe that's why it's so
tight uh the
[Music]
speed of light is a measure of that um
tension
and the speed of light
is uh constant that's why it's a
constant tension and all you have is an
atom just sliding along the ropes why
because the atom is made of those same
threads okay there's a single thread in
the entire universe so until you
understand the foundations the basics
of the rope model you cannot even you
know come up with these scenarios
because you don't understand enough
about them okay
okay and then a final issue related to
the van into the air there it is though
says if we can
uh ignore the effect of gravity do the
air molecules fall straight paths
relative to the earth or a curved path
influenced by the acceleration of the
container in other words he's saying if
the van
pulls all or drags or pushes all these
molecules of air
do the
molecules stay straight or parallel to
the earth or does it go in the direction
in which the band goes so if the band
goes on a curve the air molecule still
stays straight and the van just goes
sideways that sort of thing that's what
he's asking
and so
he continued says therefore you have the
basis of an experiment to test the
validity of the rope hypothesis
well the first thing is that in science
we don't test anything we don't prove we
don't verify
okay we don't do any of those things
that they do in mathematics
because we're talking about invisible
intangible entities there's no way
anyone can prove to you can verify for
you uh through see or touch to an
experiment
create create some evidence for you
that the rope exists okay the rope is
invisible and intangible in fact atoms
individually and individual atoms are
invisible and intangible you can't see a
hydrogen atom okay so you can't see or
touch you might touch it but you won't
know so you said did i touch it or not
you won't know
you won't know if you touch the hydrogen
atom okay so
prove to me that you touch the hydrogen
atom you touch the table contain which
contained a hydrogen atom but i don't
know maybe you touch the carbon atom or
who knows what you know we don't know
that you touch the hydrogen atom so you
can't see or touch an atom let alone the
robe which is gazillions of times
thinner than an atom okay so forget
about seat touch you're talking about
something that's beyond a plank length
okay
uh or plank width or plank energy or
whatever there's no way to see or touch
that it has no ability for a human to
see or touch the rope okay
so no experiment no evidence you'll
never find evidence this is something
that you conceptualize you visualize you
imagine okay
so you can't you can't see or touch it
uh especially because it's invisible and
tangible and meaning that if you have
that notion of the word object you have
an irrational notion of the word object
not all objects can be seen not all
objects can be touched
and um so the question for you are there
new mena numina uh in other words like
phenomena means the stuff that you can
see or touch neumann are stuff that you
cannot see or touch
and uh again these are like um uh who is
it trying to remember the philosopher
who said that um
it's an object of the mind
you can only conceptualize it you can
imagine it you can try to visualize it
that's it
so that you understand how the universe
works that's where it goes it has
nothing to do with going to the lab and
touching and seeing so you will not
determine this through an experiment
anyways the car the container will take
the air with it okay so he asked there
uh
if the car accelerates what will happen
to the air will it go straight or curved
with the car
it's very simple
why does this person have so much
problem this is very straightforward the
car will drag the air with it okay just
like i'm dragging this uh wand with my
hand because you know i'm pushing
against it well the same thing with hair
no difference so
you know these people have
i don't know
really big problems in their minds
they're irrational folk they're probably
again flat earthers and
electric universers
okay let's go with the questions that
people ask comments have people made
since last time phil says operation
mockingbird is working well the moon
landing discussion devolved into
debating flat earthers and no one even
noticed the transition
what was operation mockingbird well
that's an alleged large-scale program by
the united states central intelligence
agency that began in early years of cold
war and attempted to manipulate domestic
american news media organizations for
propaganda purposes
i don't know that's never ended and
hitler did it uh the united states does
it russia does it china does it all
mafias do it
so i don't know
why
they made such a fuss out of uh
mockingbird because
that we've been doing mockingbird since
the days of julius caesar okay it's
always been there they
get control of the press
i mean look at what's happening in
ukraine now
in the west we receive the information
united states wants and in the east they
receive the information the russians
want and
what have we learned
so don't pay attention to any of that
because it's just propaganda all of it
100 of it 150 of it
but anyways uh just to answer this oh no
it's not that um we're doing a
mockingbird here it's that uh you know
there no one raised any more issues on
the moonies on you know the moon
landings
nothing new no one was able to address
the issues that are raised and the issue
that i raised was
primarily you have this thing that
everybody can verify out there which is
the international space stations rolling
around the earth every 15 times a day
every 90 minutes
you can find the schedule in the um
at nasa's site and you'll find the
schedule you can get your binoculars
your telescope and you can look at it
and if it's out there and you'll figure
out if you've got a mathematician's
close to you he can figure out for you
how big that thing is
and it's a size of a football field
and so here you have this object the
size of a football field that you can
verify with your own eyes how did they
get up there
was it just one day they had a headache
in this and listen this thing up there
no it took
many projects you know a series of
developments
to put that thing up there in the sky
in fact in the case of the
iss it took 10 years to build it piece
by piece through the space shuttle and
other uh organizations that contributed
to it
and so it took a long time to build that
and if that thing is up there and it's
rolling around the earth something you
can verify you know if you don't believe
in that forget about the moon landings
i mean here's something you can verify
by yourself you don't need to nasa you
don't need the united states government
or anybody fooling you you know here you
can verify it for yourself
and all you need is a telescope or a
pair of binoculars very simple just go
ahead and do it and once you verify that
if that thing is up there well now you
got a problem because you say how did
that get up there why is it still
rolling around the earth how do they do
that
you know here's a monster going around
the earth
and then the issue there is uh
are there people up there and yeah these
people say you know they film how they
go up there and they do all these little
tricks and they have a million questions
on those
you know how do they drink water sound
dangerous you know you know nonsense
and um
and so these people are in low gravity
so they float around
and so yeah
we do have a a vehicle out there
in which people float around daily
because they do their work they're
called astronauts and they go out there
and they test different things you know
and so you know if we can do that if you
can at least accept that then it'll be
easier for you to understand that we did
go to the moon okay and you know all the
arguments that people raise against the
moon say look the stars in the
background the gravity is not right and
the shadows are not right and they go
through all this stuff
and they say well that was produced in a
hollywood studio
and the answer is yes okay let's go with
that tell me
tell me this is the question for you
can you tell me right
that it wasn't done
in hollywood
can you tell me the difference between
doing it for real and doing it in
hollywood i mean if hollywood can do it
and could have done it in 1969 right
let's let's go all the way here right if
hollywood could have done it in 1969 and
that was all show done here on earth can
you tell me what the difference is how
you would tell the difference
between done in hollywood and done it
for real
if you can't tell me the difference you
can't use the argument that it could
have been done in hollywood you can't
use that argument because you can't tell
me the difference that's how simple that
is and that's one issue the other issue
is that you know a lot of that
technology hollywood technology came
later
okay
people will say well so did the moon
landing all that stuff came later you
know but again i say that the russians
would have protested you know soviets
they would have uh
said a lot about the united states being
the first to be on the moon and just
like the united states would have said a
lot about gagarin being the first guy to
orbit the earth and tereshkova being the
first gal out there and uh leica the
first dog and so on you know uh
the united states could have said that
never happened
okay
now uh you can say well they did it for
propaganda to get the
ball rolling in the united states so
that everybody would get on ball with a
project with the nasa project yeah you
can come up with a million arguments my
argument is that the russians would have
said that never happened we verified
that these guys never went to the moon
etc
and the russians never did that and they
could have said that to their people and
they never did okay
so just keep all that in mind uh i mean
you know the way i look at it is uh
these people
would not have accepted that the united
states
went to the moon if they really didn't
okay another fellow here uh says uh
everything already existed uh 13.8
billion years ago it talks about a
static universe energy that we see we
see energy
man you got good eyesight okay he says
universe created quark plasma shrapnel
where did he get all these words you get
them from the establishment which he
talks against says black holes are made
of quark plasma whatever a quark is
whatever plasma is no such physical
object and again talks about energy
that's what it is all these ignorant
people they they come out here and they
bring all these this language from the
mathematical establishment they think
they're scientists i mean i don't why
don't these people just stay in church
on sunday and just leave it at that you
know
now if i said surely the singularity
must be infinitely large talking about
you know the big bang singularity or it
could be the black hole singularity as
well to anything within it okay so
here is infinitely large to anything
within it i don't know how that can be
because they say it's infinitely small
so i don't know how you can fit
infinitely big with respect to something
inside it but you're saying anything
within it okay if everything is within
it as it has no boundary right there
being nothing outside of it being
infinitely large it cannot expand into
anything since it's already infinite no
such thing as an infinite object it has
to expand against something no matter
what
okay you can't say
something is so big that it's infinitely
big no such monster either it's an
object which means it has shape means
that uh
you can visualize
its finiteness you know in other words
uh essentially right uh an object is
that which is finite and you can't say
an object that is infinite no such thing
are you saying it's growing constantly
and you can't see the edge of it you
cannot even imagine the edge of it or
what it looks like from the outside
that's not an object an object is that
which you can visualize okay completely
and that means something's got to be on
the outside no matter how you see it
and so yeah his argument is total
nonsense
and again these people try to get around
it
you know with these
you can call it logic i call it illogic
and they think they can get away with it
you know say no it's it's a finite
infinite object
well which one is it finite or infinite
you know if it's finite it's got shape
if it's infinite it's not an object
because an object is that which has
shape which is finite period we're done
it's got to have something outside of it
okay fella says actually science is a
subset of philosophy
not true it looks like science is i mean
philosophy looks like it's a branch of
science
science is rational explanations physics
explains causes and mechanisms and
philosophy explains reasons and purposes
okay one deals with object the other one
primarily the bread and butter is the
concept
okay
so yeah another philosopher comes over
and he says the following says allow me
as a philosopher to explain how this
works oh okay we got a philosopher
do note this is philosophy not science
again philosophy is a branch of science
hopefully
anyone who touches the word philosophy
is going to explain something explain
in this in the case of philosophy is
going to explain
a
behavior a purpose okay
the physic the physical cannot exist
what's that got what does exist have to
do with philosophy no such monster in
philosophy philosophy doesn't deal with
existence physics is the science of
existence okay
without the conceptual as exists the
action exists as an action
he says
the physical cannot exist without the
conceptual as exists the action right is
conceptual and is a prerequisite to the
prior being sensitive yeah exist is not
an action exist is a static concept okay
exists is actually an adjective in
physics it qualifies an object it gives
it location that's what it is there is
no motion so it's not an adverb it's an
adjective exists is an adjective not a
verb it's a verb in ordinary speech so
you can say i began to exist that that's
an ordinary speech you can't begin to
exist in physics in physics what exists
exists and that has to have be an object
first and has to have location with
respect to everything else
and so he says the prerequisite for
exists cannot be anything other than
that what functions prior to existence
the problem is a thing prior to
existence cannot exist and hence cannot
cause existence therefore existence is a
necessary self-proving value that is to
say nothing is prior to existence
this is not a unique property
well
obviously this fellow is not a
philosopher he's a [ __ ] individual
that's what he is um these people call
themselves philosophers and they're not
philosophers they think philosophy is
oh it's his way of thinking
no no if it's his way of thinking we've
got eight billion philosophers on planet
earth okay
and there's no difference between
aristotle and you why do you call it
aristotle a philosopher if you're a
philosopher and everybody else is a
philosopher if it's just a way of
thinking so hopefully philosophy is not
just a way of thinking
okay philosophy you have to explain
something because it's a branch of
science and philosophy is the branch
that explains behavior
explains specifically purposes and um
behavior your reasons
why someone does something that's that's
what philosophy is anything other than
that is not philosophy other than that
uh what you have is opinions okay people
have opinions recommendations politics
religion none of that is philosophy okay
but that's what has been mixed or
blended in with what these people call
philosophy i'm a philosopher
who knows what he studied studied
garbage in the university calls himself
a philosopher and he continued he says
the assemblage of all these necessary
self-proving values caused all things
and hence can be said
omnipotent which is the primary trait of
god
yeah god is alleged to be omnipotent and
god hence does not cause the physical
and is necessary in complete explanation
of all items okay
the flaw to the requirement of the
addition of god is that we are concerned
with physics and god is not physical as
found prior
uh
well
god looks like he's physical
there's god he looks pretty physical to
me
and even his angels
the one up there is known as bill bill
the angel
carries a baseball bat in his hand
um
all those are objects all there's a
thing so i don't know what he's saying
that it's not physical they're all
physical physical that which has shape
that's that's the definition the word
physical so i don't know what he's
talking about and again it's because he
doesn't define his terms he doesn't
define what physical is and he doesn't
define what exists means so he gets into
these ramblings he goes around in
circles and they call themselves
philosophers
they're nothing absolutely nothing
they're just like ayn rand who
kept going around in circles also
thinking she was a philosopher she
couldn't define exist and she certainly
couldn't define
entity as she called it
you know made a mess of all that
again she used she introduced sea and
touch
and experience and you know uh contact
okay fella says thought experiment for
theists and atheists okay let's see what
this is all about advanced
interdimensional
aliens land on earth okay and we asked
them if they revolt if they evolved or
were created and they say they have
always existed do you believe them if
not why
okay so we have these uh
uh inter what interdimensional
aliens okay they come to earth and they
say they've always existed and you're
supposed to say well
holy you were created or
you didn't evolve or what
which is true or they always existed
how should we answer that okay well i'll
leave it as homework i want people to
try to give it a shot i want to see what
kind of answers we get so
try to see if you can get the
interdimensional
monsters to
give you a hint whether they always
existed
were created or evolved
okay another fellow says
i agree that a wave is a concept well i
don't know if you agree because you
don't know what a concept is you haven't
defined it but it can't be explained
okay so uh wave can be explained eric
leithwaite uh did so in his video so he
pointed me to a video and people sitting
in stadiums do it you know the the wave
with their hands right
i call it the transfer of information
uh-huh
it transfers information how do you
transfer information i don't know how
you transfer concepts how do you
transfer data how do you transfer
intelligence how do you transfer low
i mean you
pick it up with tweezers and that's how
you transfer information
rather than energy since the energy
stays oh the energy stays i wonder how
many drinks this guy had you know
bartender i'll have whatever he had
energy stays how does it stay how does
it leave you know i mean energy is a
concept so is information you can't make
it stay you can't make it go you can't
transfer it you can't kick it you can't
do anything with energy but if you think
you can please draw it first so that we
know what you're kicking what your feet
comes up against
okay
and he says information is a photon
whoa
photons are mass-free since information
is merely an abstraction devoid of mass
yeah there's no physical object called
information no physical object called
mass
so um
this guy's just spinning his wheels
you know we don't know what he's saying
because he doesn't define any term he
thinks people understand it but let's
get back to the uh late weight okay this
is what he late did he he made a
simulation what a wave is the transverse
wave supposedly you know of
quantum mechanics and mathematical
physics in general and he shows how the
wave can move something forward or
backward okay and the way he does it is
by having it putting it inside the way
now what's the problem with this that
late weight never figured out and that
is that we don't know what what those
waves are in other words what's the
physical object that mediates the wave
and of course he'll never tell you that
no mathematician will they'll tell you
something stupid like you know it's the
undulation of nothing
and then the other one is that the way
he says is pushing the ball
and so this is the explanation this poor
fellow uh
accepted you know he doesn't realize how
how much nonsense he's staring at yeah
he just likes the pretty picture uh late
with just moving uh the
little bar up and down and causing the
waves and pushing the ball he likes the
art the entertainment
you know that's nice that's beautiful
no explanation whatsoever because we
don't know what a wave is we don't know
what mediates the what you know what is
the mediator of the wave in the case of
water water waves you you know the ocean
wave we say it's water in case of the
fly we say we know what it's flagging is
waving it's the flag the piece of cloth
okay so what is waving in the case of
transverse wave
light waves you know any of those waves
we don't know we have no idea
and until late with identifies those we
have he can't even start his
presentation all he did was entertain
you
as an explained absolutely anything
another foul says and yet without math
you would still be a prehistoric man
okay
because all the technology that we use
today rely on math is that so
okay well technology is not equal to
science so even if uh
math has something to do with technology
certainly math has nothing at all to do
with science okay
so he hasn't said any he hasn't
addressed the issue technology is
developed by trial and error that's how
we come up with technology and the best
case is mr thomas alva edison he said i
have not failed
i've just found 10 000 ways that won't
work
he tried one thing after another did he
do any math did he do in fact uh the guy
who criticized him was tesla he says you
know
edison is such a dope that
if he had to find a needle in a haystack
he would not stop
pulling you know straws until he found a
needle that's the way
uh edison worked he was just a hard
worker and he said he could have saved a
lot of time if he would have done a
little bit of math and calculations and
maybe come up with you know the right uh
place where the needle could be
now that was uh tesla's assessment of
edison and remember tesla worked for
edison until he
jumped ship and went to work for
westinghouse
uh anyways uh there you have it that's a
synthesis of what technology is trial
and error you try one thing it doesn't
work you try another one until you get
it better and then you get to understand
that math is developed from
measurement it's not the other way
around okay it's that math came first
and they predicted the
the behavior no they they looked at the
behavior they zeroed in with the math
and then from then on they could say
well now we can predict how this is
going to behave because we already
looked at it so many times we tweaked
the equation so much that now it's a
tactology that's what mathematics is
just tautologies
because measurement is a tautology the
equation just reflects the measurement
so it shouldn't surprise you that they
say hold the equation we predicted that
this was going to happen no kidding no
kid you measured a billion times and had
better the prediction had better come
true you know
uh anyways it's got an unsubstantiated
statement he said because all the
technology that we use today rely on
math well can you give me some examples
i mean you put no example you just said
all
and here i'll give you an example that
doesn't work uh that certainly goes
outside your claim there and that is
that you're in has math he's got the
best mathematicians on earth together
with everybody else
yet
iran doesn't have the bond
okay so here we have technology
they have the math but they don't have
the technology so i don't know
you got to think about all that okay
okay last guy over here last one in last
question last comment
person said geocentric analysis please
another flat earther i guess he believes
that geocentric meaning you know the
earth is the center of the universe or
the center of our solar system or
whichever
and everything rolls around us okay and
so here's the flat earth version i think
i mean i i don't want to put words in
their mouth this is the way i imagined
their stuff okay you have the sun
and it goes rolls around i guess or
slides around
the earth
and i do want to apologize that i didn't
put the arctic ice around the earth
i had no time so i hope you
uh forgive me for that
and then we have this a cane comparison
this is uh
our version of it okay not the earth but
the sun is at the center of our solar
system which is not the center of our
galaxy which is not the center of the
universe okay but here you have why the
earth
um
you know rolls around the earth the sun
because the sun
pulls it or or swings around by all the
roads that connect every one of the
atoms of each object okay
and uh so here we have also uh as part
of that you know the fact that the earth
is round
and
it curves the water around itself why
because
uh every atom on earth is bound to every
atom of the air in every atom of the
water
so
all atoms of the water right every
single atom is bound by electromagnetic
robes to every atom of the earth and to
every atom of on the other side of the
earth so everything pulls inward that's
why it's more or less a sphere the earth
and the air is also a shell that
encapsulates the earth why because every
atom of the earth
of air that you see there
is
tugged or pulled or really there's
tension that's i hate to use the word
pull but everybody understands the word
parole and so it's pulled towards the
center of the earth and so everything
converges upon the center that's the
issue and so yeah
what can we say we have to say that
that
we have a geocentric
solar system but we don't have a
geocentric i'm sorry a
sun-centered solar system not a
geocentric
solar system and the sun is not the
center of the galaxy and the galaxy is
not the center of the universe we're
just a tiny
speck of dust going around the sun which
is
uh a star going around the
milky way you know our galaxy which is
going who knows around what out there
okay
we we can't see everything out there but
we know we're rolling or long okay we're
moving
and you don't see any movement you don't
feel any movement well maybe you haven't
drank enough beer
uh
just one
note and that is next time i've got a
conflict of schedule on next sunday so
i'm going to have my next
[Music]
lecture on monday
so i think it's the 21st uh it's going
to be monday the 22nd okay so don't be
surprised when you see that i just got a
conflict of
schedules